ich Gründe ein Startup und nehme euch
mit auf den Weg 2022 wurden nämlich 2618
Startups gegründet aber was sind
Startups eigentlich im Prinzip sind es
junge Unternehmen mit einer innovativen
oder stark skalierbaren Geschäftsidee
wodurch sich das Feld ziemlich gut von
normalen Neugründung unterscheiden lässt
gründest du und ein Kumpel z.B
Unternehmen zur Reinigung von Fassaden
wie es hier häufig gezeigt wird wäre das
eher eine konventionelle Tätigkeit baust
du aber z.B eine Software die sich darum
kümmert Leute mit einer dreckigen
Fassade und Fassaden
Reinigungsunternehmen zusammenzubringen
wäre das vermutlich ein 33 Startups sind
in Deutschland mittlerweile beim
absoluten Holy Grail angekommen und
sogenannte unicors das bedeutet so viel
wie dass sie eine Milliarde Euro oder
mehr wert sind das bedeutet nicht dass
auf irgendeinem Firmenkonto eine
Milliarde rumliegt sondern viel mehr
dass der Wert der Firma eine Milliarden
Euro überschreitet und das geht
folgendermaßen ein Unternehmen ist in
100 Anteile aufgeteilt und sobald einer
der Anteile für 10 Millionen verkauft
wird lässt sich also hoch bzw runter
rechnen dass alle 100 Anteile zusammen
eine Milliarde oder mehr wert sind aber
wie finanziert man sowas und wie findet
man überhaupt eine Idee die irgendwann
so viel wert sein könn klickt hier um
das ganze Video zu schauen